balata refugee camp in navis the most
populated in the occupied West Bank
scarcely a wall not covered in bullet
holes residents normally prepare for
Israeli raids now they wait for news of
a
homecoming Aila Titi has been in prison
for over a year accused of trying to
stab a guard while visiting her brother
in jail her family has a long history of
suffering and resisting Israeli
occupation they say she was targeted
they say the allegations are
bogus our uncle was killed and our
brother was shot while ail was in prison
she doesn't know when she's released
she'll see life has changed yes we're
happy but it's definitely incomplete but
her family knows even a Bittersweet
reunion is not guaranteed names are on a
list but who gets to leave and when
remains in Israeli
hands elsewhere in Nablus there is more
optimism Hanan jokes about tossing her
29-year-old daughter T in the air like a
baby she was arrested at a checkpoint 15
months ago a new dress and a full house
await her simply the thought of her
release a source of
Joy I miss her so much I haven't spoken
with her in 60
days loves red fuzzy blankets I don't
have one I'm planning to buy her one
something new that she would like
hopefully she's going to be one of those
who are going to be released she says
she hopes all Israeli prisons will be
empty one
day the relatives of Palestinian
prisoners described their lives feeling
Hollow
interrupted Maha began preparing her
daughter mariam's favorite meals when
she heard the news of a prisoner swap
but she is haunted by what is happening
in
Gaza we didn't expect the swap to be
this way so many victims in Gaza and
children images that no one can
comprehend sometimes I'll say you know
what I don't want my daughter released
just let Gaza be we're so affected by
what's happening there she does not have
any family in Gaza but says they are her
people too there is excitement and
anticipation people are looking forward
to the possible return of a loved one
but we've also met people who say that
they are dreading getting their hopes up
in case it doesn't happen one one thing
that is common across the board
something everyone has said to us is
that whatever happiness may be coming
their way it will remain incomplete so
long as the people of Gaza continue to
suffer Zan basravi Al jazer Nablus in
the occupied West
Bank make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer